what this country needs is a fresh face  someone that can unite the conservative  party and get things to work in this  country  I have held nine ministerial roles three  in cabinet I was a minister before  richest United was even elected to  Parliament but more importantly than all  of that I've got real life experience I  know what people are going through right  now because I've been there I know how  complicated their lives are getting how  stressful they're getting what it's like  to Scrabble together your pennies to get  your fare to work that is why I'm  running to be prime minister of this  country because people deserve a leader  that understands the life that they lead  thank you